[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología
soy valentina torre sánchez y es un
gusto acompañarlos en esta ocasión
iniciamos en brasil entre el 17 de
febrero y el 11 de abril alrededor de
30.000 de los 45.000 habitantes de la
ciudad de serrana fueron vacunados
masivamente contra el coi 19 en un
estudio epidemiológico calificado de
único en el mundo supervisado por el
reconocido instituto butantán de brasil
con el fin de probar la efectividad de
la vacuna china coronaba del laboratorio
sinovac y analizar otros aspectos de la
pandemia pues los resultados ya fueron
publicados de acuerdo con los expertos
revelan que la pandemia de coronavirus
puede ser controlada una vez que se haya
inmunizado al 75% de la población
las muertes cayeron en un 95% las
hospitalizaciones en un 86% y los casos
sintomáticos en un 80%
conseguimos afirmar ya nos permitió
afirmar que no es una expectativa no es
un deseo es una
afirmación es posible controlar la
pandemia mediante la vacunación
a través de vacunación no precisamos y
no es necesario aislarnos o evitar el
tránsito de personas para controlar la
epidemia la clave es la vacunación a
epidemia y a destinación
los investigadores aseguran que la
principal revelación es justamente ese
75 por ciento lo que significa que no es
necesario vacunar al total de una
población para controlar la pandemia en
la ciudad fueron vacunadas todas las
personas mayores de 18 años que no
estuvieran embarazadas o fueran
lactantes y que no hubiesen presentado
cuadros de fiebre 72 horas antes de las
inyecciones por lo tanto concluyen que
la vacunación masiva de mayores de edad
hace que los menores no necesitan ser
inmunizados prioritariamente pues al
controlar el virus entre los adultos los
adolescentes y niños quedan mucho menos
expuestos
es el primer estudio en el mundo que se
ha llevado a cabo con estas proporciones
y este control es un estudio que muestra
exactamente los valores que presentamos
resultados excepcionales que dejan ver
que este es el camino el camino hacia la
salud para ayudar al mundo a lidiar con
esta pandemia o cambio
en números exactos el denominado
proyecto es se indica que el 16 de
febrero un día antes de iniciar la
vacunación masiva la ciudad tenía 2 mil
499 casos y 57 muertos a causa del virus
en marzo mes después en promedio los
casos se ubicaban en 699 y las muertes
en 30 y en abril la media de casos pasó
a 251 y la de muertes a 6 como lo
mencionado al principio las
inmunizaciones se realizaron con la
vacuna china corona vaca una fórmula
inactivada es decir que funciona
mediante el uso de partículas virales
muertas que exponen al sistema
inmunológico del cuerpo al virus sin que
haya riesgo de una enfermedad grave y
cabe resaltar que los resultados del
experimento
efectos secundarios graves tras la
aplicación del fármaco ni muertes
relacionadas entre quienes fueron
inmunizados con las dos dosis la segunda
14 días después de la primera
cambiamos ahora de tema y hablamos de
jeff bezos el fundador del gigante
amazon que anunció que viajará al
espacio el próximo 20 de julio el primer
viaje tripulado que realiza su compañía
ver la tierra desde el espacio te
transforma cambia tu relación con este
planeta con la humanidad one
hay una única tierra quiero ir en este
vuelo porque es algo que he querido toda
mi vida es una aventura es un gran reto
para mí yo formé el viaje lo realizará
en compañía de su hermano y aún hay
abierta la subasta de un asiento más en
ese primer vuelo tripulado de blue
origin compañía fundada por besos en el
año 2000 según la web la puja va en 2.8
millones de dólares
invite a mi hermano a venir en este
vuelo porque somos los amigos más
cercanos
ni siquiera esperaba que él dijera que
iba a ir en ese vuelo y luego me
preguntó si yo iría me quedé asombrado
qué increíble oportunidad no sólo para
tener esta aventura sino también para
realizarla con mi mejor amigo del
espacio viajamos a rusia donde
científicos trabajan en la ciudad de san
petersburgo desarrollando telas que se
limpian a sí mismas al entrar en
contacto con rayos ultravioleta del sol
o con agua de lluvia se trata de paños
que cuentan con un recubrimiento
especial
christchurh ulises de en el dióxido de
titanio de tamaño nanométrico juega un
papel clave en la creación de tejidos
autolimpiables tiene cualidades
fotocatalíticas es decir la capacidad de
destruir la suciedad orgánica cuando se
expone a los rayos ultravioleta y es la
base de este proceso de hexano vivo
teatro procesa los responsables aseguran
que será una tecnología clave en ropa
deportiva manteles tapicería y en
interiores de automóviles entre otros se
estima que un metro cuadrado de tela
costaría alrededor de un dólar con 8
centavos
así llegamos al final de este espacio
pero los invito a continuar con nosotros
y repetir este y otros programas en
nuestra web france24 puntocom
[Música]